well you mentioned that in order for the
for the films to be successful they had
to be made on tight tight budgets so
many of your colleagues and you yourself
have talked over the years about how
important pre-production is to making
your films can you talk a little bit
about what the pre-production process
was like for you on films made that you
were directing yourself but also that
you were producing yes well I'll start
with the actual production we were
generally shooting on a 10-day schedule
with budgets of 6070 thousand dollars
sometimes less sometimes a little more
and my theory was this and it may go
back to the engineering that when you're
shooting at they're on a tight schedule
like that you don't have time to make
important decisions you've got to just
shoot but you have all the time in the
world in pre-production so when I was
directing and then working with the HUD
directors who started with me emphasized
the importance of pre-production because
you had all the time you needed to make
your key decisions for instance to lay
out your shots in advance so you don't
come on the set the first day and say
where am I going to put the camera you
come on to set the first day you know
where you're going to put the camera and
you follow your production plan knowing
that you'll never follow that plan 100%
shot you thought of doesn't work or you
get a better idea on the set but if you
have everything laid out in advance you
can follow that schedule say 80 to 90%
and then improvised the other so as you
continue to make films into the 21st
century all of the the equipment and the
technology that's being used to make
movies is changing from using film
cameras to now digital cameras can you
talk a little bit about the the
differences in using those different
digital tools I mean on set but also in
the special effects area that so many of
your films have have explored you
in the actual shooting you can work much
faster and more efficiently not only
with the cameras with the digital
cameras which are lighter more portable
easier to work with but also sound your
lights are smaller your grip equipment
and so forth so you can shoot much
easier and much faster today with the
improved lightweight equipment during
post-production however it turns around
a little bit because when you were
shooting with film you say you say to
the crew and also to your script clerk
alright print take 4 or print of your
big time
take 14 whatever you print that one take
and you go into the editing room and
you're working with all the takes and
director is picked but one take for each
shot when you shoot digitally it is not
worth the bother in transferring to go
to the take you want it's cheaper to
print everything which means that the
director gets in to the editing room and
instead of just working with one take
for a shot he may have five takes per
shot and suddenly he's looking at all of
them and saying hey I like take two even
though I said print take eight or
something like that and so you're
slowing down the process the other thing
of course is digital effects primarily
computer graphics the quality is
phenomenal it's so much better than
anything we ever used but frankly it
takes forever I'm finishing up a picture
this is death race 2000 I'm finishing up
a picture for universal death race
twenty fifty fifty years later and
the the crashes the stunts and
everything will be real but there will
also be computer graphics oh they'll be
much better but as usual we're behind
schedule on the computer graphics ever
every picture I've ever done with
computer graphics has been behind
schedule